it's been sitting here more than 15
months the russian-owned Antonoff an-124
the cargo plane came to Canada to
deliver a shipment of covid-19 Rapid
antigen tests but the plane's been
unable to fly in Canadian airspace since
Russia invaded Ukraine
now the Canadian government says it's
seizing the plane and giving it to
Ukraine this is a big first step to
seize their assets the aircraft was
manufactured in Ukraine we're hoping
that Ukraine will be able to use it to
transport Aid that's being donated from
around the world Aviation lawyer Bill
Clark it'll go back it'll be given to
the Ukrainian government who would then
you know delegate it to the Antonov
design Bureau who built the fight the
federal government announced plans over
the weekend to seize the plane when
prime minister Justin Trudeau made a
surprise trip to Kiev we are one of the
first countries to bring in specific
legislation that allows us not just to
ground this plane but to actually seize
it Trudeau says the Ukrainian
government's happy with the move and is
there a timeline as soon as possible
legalities aside the plane is in no
condition to go anywhere without
maintenance every aircraft has what we
call a maintenance control manual that
specifies what has to be done in laps
none of that has been done and Ukrainian
Canadians are wondering what's next when
it comes to seizing Russian assets there
absolutely needs to be more done to
investigate and and freeze assets and
then eventually as you see with this
plane to seize it
getting the legal work done step one
getting the plane airworthy again step
two as for the one thousand dollar a day
Pearson parking Bill well the federal
government will likely waive that for
the new owners Sean Shea Global News
Toronto